best has gardener land in bavaria
a mountainous idle on the austrian
border
now the number one coronavirus hotspot
in germany
the number of new cases there in the
last week is five
times above the threshold for a
high-risk area
as of tuesday locals are back in
lockdown and only allowed to leave their
homes with a valid reason
the number of new daily cases in germany
is rising nationwide
with the south and the west worst hit
more than 129
areas are now deemed high risk as the
second wave hits berlin
authorities are urging people to wear
masks in all crowded places where social
distancing isn't possible
masks are compulsory at markets while
queueing and on some shopping streets
for now the public is largely remaining
calm
of course we're afraid but not in the
sense that you think about it all the
time
but we're protecting ourselves just like
before
i still live with my parents so i won't
go panic buying but i already found it
bad the first time around
and this time too
i think we're better prepared this time
around compared to the first time
i see how people are behaving and it's
much better
[Music]
but what it means for us i'm in berlin
for the first time in 10 months
and of course i'm a bit afraid
in political spheres pressure is growing
for more involvement of the parliament
in coronavirus decision-making
bundestag president wolfgang scheubler
wrote to mps on monday
saying that parliament's role as
lawmaker must be more distinct in the
handling of the pandemic
a polite reminder that in germany's
democracy parliament makes the laws
not the government we are joined now
here in the studio by
excuse me we're joined from bashes
gardenerland by yulia
saudelli um julia tell us why are
infections there
so high
well uh on monday when the lockdown
measures were announced
um minister president of bavaria zoda
suggested that it all could be connected
to a party that happened here in the
area
others have alleged that the close
area of curtin in austria which has been
a hot spot and has been put into
lockdown since last week
could have also been a source of new
infections
but local authorities here are saying
that there is
no clear indication that one event
triggered the spread of the virus
it is a widespread event the virus is
everywhere here and they can't trace it
back to one single event
how are people there coping with the
lockdown
well people here are going about their
business they are walking their dogs
they're going to the bakery and shopping
they're doing what they are allowed to
do
they say that they are okay with the new
restrictions with the stay-at-home order
if that helps bring the infection
numbers down obviously they're not very
excited of having to spend
more time at home but what they say is
that they're lucky that they live in a
beautiful mountainous area and that they
are still allowed to
go out for walks tell us a little bit
more about the local economy because
it's highly dependent on tourism
what does that mean for the lockdown
the situation is troubling for people
here many own hotels have
businesses restaurants or shops and what
we have seen today
is a lot of these situations where
they are closed we have seen hotels
locked down restaurants close
and that is a big loss in income for the
owners
2 500 tourists were here and had to
leave suddenly yesterday
at 2pm when the lockdown came into
effect
and people are worried that these two
important weeks where
a lot of people are on holiday it is a
school fall holiday season
that a lot of these uh the money that
was meant to come in
won't and that they will have lost it
thank you so much dw's yulia saldelli
reporting from bachelor's gardenerland
we appreciate it we go first to spain
which is nearing one million covid19
infections standing by for us in sevilla
is dw's yon phillip schultz
how is the country there coping with the
latest strike
well the situation here in spain is once
again very tense
and what makes it even worse is that the
pressure on the healthcare system
is rapidly increasing i received a
message from a medical doctor
who works in a local hospital here in
sevilla yesterday
and what she wrote really sounds like a
cry for help
let me just quote a few sentences
she writes i'm sending you this message
because here at the hospital we are
deeply worried
the numbers have skyrocketed skyrocketed
the emergency unit is full
it's horrible and it will get even worse
i'm not alarmist i'm just realistic
and she also says that she feels that in
the coming days it's even
going to get worse so i'm afraid no good
news at all here from spain
yarnfield schultz in spain
and belgium is also one of the corona
hot spots in europe with new
restrictions in place since monday
barbara basil standing by
in brussels how is the belgian
government trying to get the outbreak
under control the belgian government is
desperately trying to stave off a second
real
lockdown so they've closed all bars
restaurants
they have put out a nightly curfew
you're not supposed to go out at night
at all anymore limited the sale of
alcohol
everything we've already seen in france
but
they're also appealing to its citizens
to sort of
stick to the rules you're not supposed
to meet more than one
other person here outside of your direct
family and so they're really playing for
time but the figures seem to be running
away from them they've seen a 70
increase of new infections throughout
the last 10 days
and they also fear that by mid-november
all their emergency beds in the
hospitals could be full
so desperate holding measure measures
and they don't know yet whether this is
going to work
barbara basil in brussels thank you
and poland was praised for successfully
controlling the virus in march and april
olivia cortes is in
warsaw what's the situation now
the situation at the moment is really
alarming earlier this year in spring
poland introduced one of the earliest
and
toughest lockdowns of all of europe and
was hit less hard however right now the
government
is failing to curb the infection rates
we
hear more and more reports from
hospitals that cannot take
patients anymore and at the moment the
government even turns the national
stadium in warsaw into a field hospital
where he reports that similar emergency
entities will be established
in the rest of the country the system is
not breaking down yet
but we expect it to reach its limits in
a couple of weeks
thank you so much
you